[Music]
data comes in many shapes and sizes in
the last videos we introduced apache
beam and walked through a batch data
processing job
but how do you handle processing
streaming data
let's get into it
first things first we need to define
batch processing and stream processing
batch processing uses data that has a
fixed size because it represents a data
set that's already completed we went
through one example by looking at all of
the words in shakespeare's king lear in
the last video
but it could also be a much larger data
set like all the words in every book in
a library
once you get your hands on all of the
data you can start processing it
beam refers to this type of data as
bounded because you already have all the
data you'll want to work with
stream processing uses unbounded data
where you don't have a complete set of
data because it's still being updated
if you think about a social media feed
for example there's constantly new data
being added and you may need to process
new events as they come in
since the data set won't ever be
complete you need to process events as
they stream in and compute results on
aggregated data in order to process
unbounded data beam uses something
called windows let's break down what
windows are
in beam a window generally represents a
range of time by default beam will put
every piece of data into the global
window which represents the range of
time between negative infinity and
infinity when you perform any operations
or transforms on your data they will
apply to the entire window this is what
you'll usually want when working with a
batch processing job but what happens
when you're working with an unbounded
data set
instead of using the entire global
window you can divide elements between
smaller intervals of time these windows
represent time ranges so you can process
the data in each one
for example you could have 60-minute
windows and count the number of elements
in each window the count of each window
would tell you how many pieces of data
were processed for each hour
because each window is eventually
complete you can process them
independently and produce a final answer
for that window
the global window will contain all the
data as it's being processed but that's
a pretty large range of time when you
define how you want your data to be
windowed you can configure things like
how large the windows are and whether or
not they'll overlap
before we dive deeper into exactly how
windows work though the right
configuration depends on how you want to
process your data based on its timestamp
but what do we mean by a timestamp
well if we think about an event that
happens on a mobile device it's easy
enough to grab the time that the event
happened according to the device we call
this event time
however that event will also need to be
sent to a system like beam for
processing there will always be a
difference between the time that the
event actually happened and when the
event is processed or the processing
time
especially when you're receiving events
from multiple devices with different
connectivity and latency these events
will almost always arrive out of order
if you use processing time to aggregate
your events you'll only get an
approximate result at best instead
you'll want to use the event time to
handle your data correctly and get
accurate results let's take a look at an
example so we can see why processing
time won't give you accurate results and
go over how windows work here's a simple
example data set of events that you
might see for a mobile application
we can see that each of these events is
for the same user id and each item
represents different user actions like
tapping or swiping
for this data the event time property
will represent the actual time that the
event happened and was collected on the
mobile device
to keep things simple for this video
we'll look at the event time as a number
of seconds rather than showing a full
unix timestamp
if we wanted to aggregate and count the
number of events for this user it would
be a pretty straightforward count we
could group the events by the user id
and then count them which would give us
a total count of five events
as we mentioned before even though we're
looking at these events ordered by
timestamp there's no guarantee that
they'll actually arrive for processing
in this order
data in a distributed environment may be
inherently unordered and the apache beam
model doesn't make any assumptions about
data ordering that's why we mentioned in
earlier videos that p collections are
immutable and unordered
okay back to our example data
we know that there are some events and
we want to process them if we had all of
the events ahead of time we could
consider it bounded data and use a batch
processing job
in reality we'll often want to process
unbounded data with the possibility of
more events coming in at any time and
handle events arriving out of order that
means we'll need windows
if we don't configure anything for
windows beam will place all of our
elements in the global window if we
wanted to get a count for the events
we'd have to wait for the data to be
complete and since our example
represents unbounded data new events
could arrive at any time and the window
will never be complete
there is a way to get speculative
results when working with unbounded data
but we'll talk more about that in
another video
in order to get the complete results
we're looking for we'll need to
subdivide the data into groups that we
know will eventually complete using
windows
we'll start by using fixed windows these
are the windows of the same size that
repeat like every hour or every 15
seconds using our same data from before
we can use fixed windows that have a
size of five seconds using these windows
we can do a simple aggregation by
counting the data inside of each window
after the window is complete
so the first window has a count of three
events and the second window has a count
of two events the right size for your
window depends on your use case and your
data but you can specify the length to
beam and it takes care of the rest
beam can estimate and track when a
window is complete which we'll talk
about more later in this video
however we did talk about this being
unbounded data that means more events
could come in at any time and they're
not guaranteed to arrive in the same
order that they happened
and just like that
here's a new event
while this event looks the same as our
other ones the event time is actually at
4 seconds so the event itself would have
happened before the events that happened
at 6 and 8 seconds
since data like this can continue to
arrive at any time beam needs to
determine when to stop adding new events
and process the data inside of a window
to produce output
triggers are the mechanisms that beam
actually uses to emit the aggregated
results for each window
the default after watermark trigger can
be overridden and there's multiple types
of triggers that you can customize
depending on how you want to process
your data we'll talk more about those in
the next video too
when collecting and grouping data into
windows beam uses a watermark to keep
track of how up-to-date the events in
that window are
as data flows through a pipeline beam
keeps track of the oldest event
timestamp that it expects to see at each
step this is how beam can handle and
estimate when a window is actually
complete and all the data is expected to
have arrived which also means beam can
process the complete window
once the watermark for a window has
passed the default after watermark
trigger will emit the results for that
window any data that arrives for that
window after this point is considered
late data which we'll also discuss in
the next video
let's see what this looks like with our
example data since we're trying to
illustrate the differences between event
time and processing time we'll take a
look at when these events actually
arrived in bean
this is a pretty optimistic example
because most of our event time and
processing times are very close together
however the last event has a bit more
delay since we're using 5 second windows
the data will be split into 2 windows
the tap event at 8 seconds was actually
processed at 9 seconds but the overall
data would still be processed in the
same way since that event is still part
of the same window
on the other hand the final swipe event
has an event time of 4 seconds but was
processed at 9 seconds
if we were using the processing time in
our windows we'd have three events in
each window but that doesn't reflect
when the events actually happened we
would normally want that new swipe event
in the first window since that's
actually accurate as to when the event
happened
so we can see that using event time is
the right way to get accurate results
but beam still needs a way to know when
it can expect all the data in each
window to have arrived since
out-of-order data could arrive at any
time beam needs to use a watermark to
estimate when the window is actually
complete let's look at just the events
that would be contained by our first
window
because the process time for the final
event is after the closing time for the
window whether or not it makes it into
that window depends on the watermark the
delay and reordering between event
arrival can vary over time so the
watermark will make progress at
different rates if the watermark for
this window hasn't passed until after
the new event is processed then that
event will make it into the window once
the watermark passes the window will be
processed with all four events in it
but if beam determines that the
watermark has passed before the new
event is processed beam would close the
window without including the event and
discard it as late data
this is the default behavior for
handling late data and just like most of
what we talked about in this video you
can customize how late data is handled
so to recap what we've talked about in
this video there's bounded and unbounded
data sets which are aligned with batch
and stream processing
beam uses windows to handle data
dividing up the data into segments so
it's easier to work with
fixed windows have distinct starting and
ending times for the data that goes into
them
using event time gives you accurate
results rather than using processing
time and beam uses after watermark as
the default trigger to know when there
is no more data to be expected in a
window we'll talk about handling late
data triggers and different kinds of
windows in the next video so stay tuned
and thanks for watching
[Music]